Thank you to Private Internet Access for sponsoring
today’s episode!
PIA provides a secure, reliable VPN connection.
Click the link in the description below to
receive 82% off the first two years, plus
four months of free service.
We here at the Journey to the Microcosmos
headquarters have been very excited about
this ciliate, which is called Legendrea loyezae.
James, our master of microscopes, found it
in a lake, which made him just one of five
people in human history who
had ever found this organism.
In our last episode, we talked about how his
discoveries managed to reconcile the contradictions
that had gone unexplained in the observations
previous scientists had made.
What we didn’t talk about was the fact that
James and his collaborators, Dr. Demetra Andreou
and Professor Genoveva F. Esteban, were the
first people to gather genetic data about
the Legendrea genus, thanks in part to their
little Legendrea loyezae friends.
Now when we say “genetic data,” we could
be referring to a lot of different things,
in part because genes are such an extensive,
varied landscape that humans are only in the
early days of being able to describe.
Genes contain the instructions that tell our
cells how to make the proteins that carry
out our lives as they drive chemical reactions
or produce key structures or pass along information.
And those instructions are written in the language
of DNA, a double helix whose components spell
out individual bits of a message, like letters
building up to a word that builds up to a
manual for life.
To make that language comprehensible to us,
scientists use the letters A, T, G, and C
to represent the chemical bases that link
together to form that code.
But within every living organism, whether
it is us or the organisms we’re watching,
that code is a living, churning, evolving
force that enshrines our identity in relation
to so many others.
In our journey through the microcosmos, we have
often seen the way genetic material and the
use of phylogenetic techniques reveal new
ways to see an organism’s identity or to
upend a set of relationships we thought existed
in the microcosmos, like when scientists realized
that the organisms they had gathered together
in the taxonomic category of “amoeba”
were not really so closely related after all.
The idea is simple: let’s compare organisms
and see if we can figure out—based on their
similarities and differences—how closely
related they are.
We can—and have—done this with microscopes
and extensive descriptions of what different
microbes look and act like.
But like we said, genetics has often upended
what we have gleamed just through observation.
But to study organisms at the genetic level,
we need their DNA.
Which means that we need to be able to wade
through all the bits and pieces lying within
their tiny bodies to pick out something even
tinier—something we can’t just dig out
with a shovel.
So how?
How does James manage to get the precious
DNA from Legendrea loyezae and other ciliates
he is interested in studying?
He starts by grabbing the whole organism,
separating it from the crowd in a manner similar
to what you can see him doing here with some
other microbes.
There they are, just chilling, until James
appears with a tool called a micropipette
that draws them right up.
After taking the ciliate he is interested
in, it’s time for James to give it a little
bath to make sure that it is clean and
removed any organism that might cloud
up the results.
He starts by squirting the organism into a
clean drop of water and letting it swim around
for a while.
Then, grabbing a new, clean micropipette,
James repeats the process again.
And again, and again, and again.
Each time, using a new micropipette to drop
the organism into a fresh drop of water.
The goal is to get the ciliate very, very
clean.
And that means James sometimes has to leave
them swimming for as long as 30 minutes in
that drop of water.
And that’s not just to scrub their outsides.
The insides need to be empty of any ciliates
they might have eaten, that are now taking
up residence inside of a food vacuole.
Yes, even a master of microscopes has to wait
around a bit for a ciliate to poop sometimes.
When he’s done and the ciliates are cleaned
up, James freezes them in a tiny tube, getting
them ready for the next step: isolating the
DNA.
The process is simple: he takes the tube out
of the freezer and lets it thaw out.
And then he puts it back into the freezer
and lets it ice up again.
Just like the washing, this is a repetitive
process.
Over and over again, the organism is frozen,
then thawed, frozen, then thawed.
Each time, the cell changes a little bit.
Ice pierces through the membrane, and the
insides of the cell begin to disintegrate.
Buried in the cellular soup that remains
is the organism’s DNA.
Now separating that DNA requires a technique that
you have probably heard a lot about in the
past few years: PCR, which stands for polymerase
chain reaction.
The goal of PCR is to take a small amount of DNA
and then make many, many more copies of it.
During the pandemic, we relied on PCR to find
fragments of viral RNA in our mucus, and then
to amplify it so that those small quantities
of genetic material could be detectable.
But PCR is so important that even describing
it as a tool to save lives during a pandemic
feels like we are underselling it.
It is one of the tools whose premise is
so simple that it can be used and adapted
for any number of applications.
Since its discovery in 1985, PCR has been
fundamental to the work of scientists who
are doing everything from hunting down proteins
to engineering new technologies to creating
new medical therapies.
For today though, PCR’s main use to us is
to gather small segments of the Legendrea
loyezae’s DNA that can be used to find where
it belongs taxonomically.
And as with the previous steps that James
had to undertake, there is a lot of repetition.
The ciliate that was cleaned over and over
again, and then frozen and thawed over and
over again will now have its contents heated
and cooled in a mixture that will tear apart
the strands of DNA and find the parts that
James wants to amplify, over and over again.
With each repetition, the number of DNA fragments
goes up exponentially so that in the end,
James is holding a tube full of them, ready
to be sent off so that a machine can determine
its sequence of As, Ts, Cs, and Gs for scientists
to study further.
With his prized DNA, James was able to find
a family for the Legendrea loyezae: the family
Spathidiidae, Order Haptorida.
He was even able to find a sibling: Epispathidium
papilliferum.
They even have similar protruding structures,
making their family resemblance apparent beyond
the genetic similarities.
This is a relationship that the early observers
of Legendrea loyezae might not have been able
to infer.
And even if they did, the tools to verify
them didn’t exist.
Each time we visit the microcosmos, it’s
with knowledge and tools
that we did not have before.
That is why it matters to discover again
what someone found once before, to dig through
old texts and familiar ponds.
Because buried deep within, there is always
something unknown remaining to be found.
Thank you for coming on this journey with us as
we explore the unseen world that surrounds us.
And thank you again to Private Internet Access
for sponsoring today’s episode.
PIA provides a secure, reliable VPN connection.
But you might be asking yourself, “what
is a VPN?”
Well, a VPN is a Virtual Private Network that
encrypts your internet data, and hides your
IP address, keeping your information secure
and protected.
But it also allows you to watch streaming
content that may not be available in your area.
PIA has a next-gen server infrastructure covering
over 83 countries and each and every US state!
Let’s say you’re in the mood to cozy up
with some hot cocoa, sit by the fire, and
watch the classic film “White Christmas”.
Well, if you’re in the US, that's as simple
as loading up Netflix and typing in “White Christmas”.
But if you are outside of the US, you will not
find White Christmas when you search for it.
But thanks to PIA, you won’t have to miss
out on a Christmas classic, because you can
access US-exclusive content, no matter where
you are!
Private Internet Access works with all major
streaming services, so you have access to
all your favorite content anywhere in the
world.
And PIA is available for all platforms, and
one subscription protects up to 10 devices
at the same time.
You have a 30-day money-back guarantee if
you don’t like the product or if it doesn’t
meet your expectations, and right now PIA
VPN is offering Microcosmos viewers their
best deal yet– an 82% discount and 4 free
months when you use the link piavpn.com/microcosmos.
The names on the screen right now, they are
the people who allow us to make Journey to
the Microcosmos and continue diving deeper
into our world, how we understand it, the
work people have done throughout history,
and the work that is being done right now.
We are so grateful to all of you, if you would
like to join them and become one of the reasons
why we can do that, you can go to Patreon.com/JourneyofMicro.
If you want to see more from our Master of
Microscopes, James Weiss, and look, why wouldn't
you, you can check out Jam and Germs on Instagram.
And if you wanna see more from us, there's
always a subscribe button somewhere nearby.